[Música]
acabamos de escuchar pájaros
precisamente vencejos golondrinas
gorriones cotorras urracas gaviotas mir
los carboneros currucas herrerillos
verdecillos verderones petirrojos
palomas y tórtolas
15 especies diferentes cada una con su
propio canto y si nos hemos fijado a lo
mejor también habremos escuchado una voz
hablando en catalán y un peculiar sonido
de ambulancia que hace pop y pop pop y
pop pop hip hop
esta combinación de sonidos nos permite
deducir que estamos en barcelona en un
lugar con árboles y si estamos en
barcelona también podemos deducir que
debe ser primavera o verano ya que los
vencejos y las golondrinas solo se
quedan aquí en la temporada cálida
todas estas informaciones las podemos
obtener sin ni siquiera abrir los ojos
tan sólo escuchando nos podemos situar
en el espacio y en el tiempo
de la misma manera si escuchamos el
espacio en el que nos encontramos ahora
podemos deducir informaciones sobre su
dimensión los materiales de construcción
nuestra posición en ello y si nos
fijamos más unidos recibiremos todavía
más informaciones por ejemplo hay un
proyector que hace
[Música]
he querido empezar así escuchando porque
quería encender activar nuestras orejas
invitaros a observar y cuestionar
nuestro entorno sonoro y nuestra forma
de escucharlo
porque escuchar con atención con
curiosidad con conciencia puede ser muy
interesante incluso más interesante que
mirar y sobre todo puede hacer que
nuestras vidas nuestras sociedades
nuestra tierra sean más ricas más
felices y más sanas
pero que hay que escuchar
pues todo
la música las voces de las personas con
las que hablábamos los sonidos que nos
gustan pero esto es muy fácil y
seguramente ya lo estamos haciendo
lo que yo os propongo es de dar un paso
más
y escuchar todo nuestro interno sonoro
con todos sus sonidos
todos sus elementos sonoros tan
naturales como culturales tan agradables
como desagradables los sonidos que
llaman nuestra atención pero también
esos sonidos que nuestro cerebro
naturalmente filtra porque no los
consideran relevantes con el proyector
seguramente muchos entre entre vosotros
ya habréis descubierto algunas de las
maravillas del paisaje sonoro o
explorado ruido o el sonido de los
objetos o hallado compositores que
emplean los sonidos del entorno en sus
obras
olivier messiaen por ejemplo se
inspiraba en los cantos de las aves para
su lenguaje musical pero esta no es una
exclusiva occidental al revés es común
en muchísimas culturas del mundo
por ejemplo en etiopía se cree que el
arte musical fue revelado al santo
músico jared por tres pájaros enviados
por dios
la bioacústica la ciencia que estudia
los sonidos de la naturaleza de la
naturaleza nos permite aprender sobre
los animales incluso sin verlos
si empleamos micrófonos subacuáticos
para escuchar el mar descubriremos
entonces que lo que el famoso
oceanógrafo jacques cousteau llamaba el
mundo del silencio se ha convertido hoy
en día en un mundo muy ruidoso en el que
los cetáceos pierden su camino hasta
mueren a causa de la grave contaminación
acústica que les obligamos a soportar
pero el ruido no solo los afecta a ellos
sino genera reacciones fisiológicas de
estrés en todos los seres vivientes
incluso en nosotros y si nos molesta la
música del vecino el camión de la basura
imaginad como debe ser
vivieron un entorno sonoro de guerra
pero no he venido aquí para transmitir
preocupación para qué asociase la
conciencia acústica con el malestar
todo lo contrario he venido aquí para
contaros de la belleza de la escucha
para invitaros a practicarla ya
disfrutar de todos los beneficios que
puede aportar en todos los ámbitos del
conocimiento la música la urbanística la
arquitectura la política la sanidad el
arte la educación el diseño
la ecología la cultura mucho más
los sonidos de cada lugar en cada época
nos hablan de su salud natural y social
pero sobre todo son un vehículo
milagroso importante de informaciones y
emociones
y proporcionan a los individuos y las
comunidades un sentido de identidad de
continuidad y por esta razón se pueden
considerar el paisaje sonoro se puede
considerar como parte de nuestro
patrimonio inmaterial
además el paisaje sonoro ocupa el
espacio público
entonces imaginar qué pasaría si antes
de diseñar un espacio público se
preguntara al público cómo le gustaría
que sonara
imaginad si antes de abrir una escuela
un hospital un comedor una oficina de
correos se os preguntara cómo queréis
que suene
a lo mejor alguien se quedaría perplejo
no sabría qué contestar pues esto se
debería al hecho que su escucha no está
muy educada
entonces cómo se educa la escucha
pues es muy fácil porque escuchar no es
una habilidad es una decisión
para ser escuchado es curiosos y
conscientes tan solo tenemos que tomar
la decisión ya es una decisión que
podemos tomar todas y todas en cualquier
momento no hay ninguna restricción no
hay ningún requisito eso sí nadie puede
tomar la decisión por otra persona
la decisión de escuchar es libre pero es
completamente individual
habréis notado que ha insistido un poco
en las palabras curiosos y conscientes
entonces me gustaría proponer unos
ejercicios para explicar lo que quiero
decir y también para entrenar si queréis
vuestra curiosidad y conciencia sonora
una vez
vuestra decisión de escuchar ya esté
tomada
usar el cuerpo
para evitar distracciones visuales por
ejemplo cerrar los ojos o bien emplear
las manos para direccionar nuestra
escucha hacia la fuente sonora
sentir como percibimos las vibraciones
en diferentes partes del cuerpo
2 usar el corazón
hacer una lista de todos los sonidos que
nos emocionan los sonidos de nuestra
infancia los sonidos de nuestra memoria
de nuestros lugares y seres queridos y
poner al lado de cada sonido la emoción
correspondiente
usar la mente
con la misma curiosidad con la que
cuando escuchamos una música que nos
gusta nos informamos sobre el intérprete
y cómo podemos volver a escucharla
informarnos sobre todos los sonidos de
nuestro alrededor
ya veremos es como beber a un pozo de
conocimiento que nunca se agota
4 usar el espacio todo el espacio
caminar buscando diferentes puntos de
escucha buscar el lugar más silencioso y
el más ruidoso buscar umbrales sonoros
por ejemplo entrando de un espacio
abierto a un espacio cerrado
5 usar la imaginación
buscar patrones melódicos y rítmicos en
el paisaje sonoro como podría ser el pop
y pop de la ambulancia de antes o el
toto un totum de un tren hay mucha
música en el paisaje pues a disfrutarla
6 usar palabras para describir los
sonidos que escuchamos
en los estudios sensoriales muchos
expertos están de acuerdo que el
desarrollo de un vocabulario sensorial
ayuda también a mejorar la
perceptibilidad entonces utilicemos
nuestro idioma al fin y al cabo si no
fuera por el sonido el idioma hablado ni
siquiera existiría
17 el ejercicio más importante buscar el
silencio
el silencio nos hace más atentos más
dispuesto a escuchar
entonces me gustaría
disfrutarlo con vosotros ahora mismo
cerrando los ojos durante 33
respiraciones lentas
qué tal
bien
es que para conectar con nuestro espacio
sonoro primeramente tenemos que
tranquilizarnos y conectar con nosotros
mismos y es un ejercicio que sienta muy
bien
además nos permite observar cuando no
estamos escuchando entonces podemos
volver a tomar la decisión
y si hasta aquí no se ha animado a
practicar la escucha en vuestras vidas
diarias os contaré algunos de sus
beneficios
cuanto más escuchemos mejor aprenderemos
a ordenar los sonidos según su
intensidad su distancia su frecuencia su
timbre nos podremos separar en capas
como si escucháramos los instrumentos de
la orquesta por separado
conectaremos mejor con nuestro entorno
entonces reconoceremos mejor lo que es
bueno para nuestra salud para nuestra
comunidad
nuestras relaciones sociales también
mejorarán ya que dejaremos de hablar más
fuerte de hablar encima y antes que nada
escucharemos y así aprenderemos a
detectar las emociones sutiles que
vehicula la voz comunicarnos mejor con
las personas que sienten esas emociones
además mejoraremos naturalmente nuestro
oído musical y por supuesto
disfrutaremos de nuestros paseos porque
podremos reconocer muchas especies de
aves
como decía a reimond muere software el
padre de la ecología acústica todos y
todas somos simultáneamente es
simultáneamente auditores e intérpretes
y compositores de nuestro paisaje sonoro
entonces es nuestra responsabilidad
hacer que suene bien
si cada uno de nosotros y de nosotras
decidiera lo más frecuentemente posible
de escuchar con curiosidad y con
conciencia todos los sonidos de su
alrededor estoy segura que en un tiempo
muy breve tanto nuestras vidas como
nuestras sociedades y nuestro patrimonio
cultural y natural ganarían inmensamente
en salud bienestar riqueza belleza y paz
gracias por escuchar
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]